les masques arrive dans des sacs bio
hazard identifier ces sacs remplis de
masques n95 utilisé une seule fois
prennent habituellement le chemin de la
poubelle
mais depuis deux jours à l'hôpital
sainte justine on essaye une nouvelle
technologie est là on procède à une
spéciale d'abord on s'assure que le
masque n'est pas souillée et à garder sa
forme initiale
chaque n95 et identifier avec le nom de
celui qui l'a portée et son département
il nie les utilisatrices les masques
sont ensuite accrochés en suspension sur
cette étagère dans une salle qui est
scellée dès que les masques ont été
installées il reste alors à débuter la
désinfection avec cet équipement
l'agent désinfectant si du peroxyde
d'hydrogène liquide qui va se
transformer en vapeur donc la machine va
diffuser la vapeur de peroxyde
d'hydrogène
après la procédure qui dure de 6 à 7
minutes seulement
les masques sont alors transférés dans
une salle d'aération pendant plusieurs
heures les tests sont plus
qu'encourageants et l'hôpital estime que
le nettoyage peut être répété au moins
jusqu'à cinq fois je me sens tout à fait
à l'aise pour dire quel est le processus
fonctionne un contre les virus pour les
hôpitaux québécois et canadien cela
viendrait donc régler en partie les
problèmes éventuels d'approvisionnement
quand on sait qu'ils nous à risque et
trois jours ça devient un peu angoissant
maintenant les retraites en est capable
de gagner trois jours l'entreprise 3m
qui fabrique les masques ne recommande
pas la réutilisation pour des raisons
commerciales probables mais le nettoyage
et sécuritaire si j'ai à choisir entre
mon personnel la santé qui n'a rien à se
mettre sur le visage pour les traiter un
patient et qui risque de contracter la
maladie
versus un produit qui est retraité avec
des barèmes de qualité qu'on est capable
de suivre pour moi c'est évident si tout
va bien dans les prochaines semaines
après validation des résultats
la procédure pourra être étendue ici et
à d'autres hôpitaux